the anti-government protests are now in
their fourth week and once again
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets across the country
caracas is host to the biggest crowds
and they came from all over the capital
cramming into a huge avenue in the city
center
[Applause]
they want to hear this man speak Wang
wieder is the torchbearer of the
opposition movement they love him here
just getting to the stage is a mission
for his security guards the entrant
first couple don't disappoint the crowd
this relatively unknown politician is
now a superstar who's urging the people
to keep coming to the streets to protest
against Nicolas Maduro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the question really is whether friend
wide open keep up the momentum on the
streets weakened but weak out at this
stage many here thought maduras reign
would have ended by now but he's
refusing to budge Lilian Tim Torrey is
widely credited with convincing foreign
nations and in particular the United
States to support the opposition moves
here
she says the opposition is still winning
and how long before Maduro goes do you
think I think I think today or tomorrow
soon soon of course because they don't
have people like they motor only have
arms violence and arms and then it's
better than one like that but as though
doubt that this can end peacefully
I don't know what's gonna happen I don't
know but I suppose it could be violent
though across town another rally this
one for Nicolas Maduro however one views
it though the numbers are tiny in
comparison to the Guido rally the square
where it was held in the streets around
a very small it's still very much
supporting Maduro here we really have a
political impasse in Venezuela now
[Music]
Maduro has lost the streets but he
hasn't lost the military and for now at
least that gives him the upper hand
still panties can use correct